[Musique]
nouvelle édition des journées du
patrimoine c'est l'occasion à travers
l'histoire de ce territoire de re
découvrir notre patrimoine art de
multiples visites vous sont proposés
château de lamotte champdeniers à sur
les trois moutiers la maison de l'acadie
à chausser château de pure non avis rue
et puis ici la tour carrée de boudin qui
a été magnifiquement restauré par la
municipalité boudin un millénaire
d'histoire depuis l'autre sept tours
pour lui par contre que des rats on
retrouve toute la géographie plus d'une
heure autour de nous et plus vous invite
évidemment à venir découvrir les travaux
du chantier au château de
monts-sur-guesnes qu'historien ouvrira
le 26 mai 2022 englund la première est
pompée celle d'aliénor et de richard
coeur de lion alors c'est pour nous un
soutien fort pour le patrimoine parce
que c'est un volet évidemment essentiel
pour l'économie du bâtiment c'est un
volet essentiel également pour le
tourisme
venez donc découvrir re votre patrimoine
venez redécouvrir ce patrimoine venez
redécouvrir votre territoire
[Musique]
on